ils étaient une cinquantaine des membres
de la fdsea et des agriculteurs devant
le palais de justice de versailles ils
manifestaient contre les méthodes de
l'association de protection animale l214
en décembre dernier deux de leurs
membres s'étaient introduits dans
l'abattoir dude en filmant notamment
l'étourdissement des ports au co2 une
pratique malhonnête selon la fdsea
il ya deux choses qu'il faut bien
distinguer il ya la violation de
propriété pour y installer des caméras
et puis il ya l'argument que met en
avant l'association l214 sur la
maltraite la soi-disant maltraitance des
animaux
en fait tous les éleveurs qui sont ici
qui sont ou se réunit aujourd'hui où
tous les éleveurs qui en font leur
métier ont qu un seul souci en tête
au quotidien c'est bien évidemment le
bien-être animal c'est ce bien-être
animal il est encadré par la loi depuis
des décennies depuis les dizaines
d'années et ne s'arrête pas là pour eux
l'association l214 prônent avec ses
actions le véganisme et souhaite tout
simplement poussé l'opinion à ne plus
manger de viande donc la mort de leur
métier
du côté de l214 ce jugement va surtout
permettre de mettre le débat sur la
table on a un débat qui se trouve à être
intéressant entre le travail d'une ong
qui essayent de témoigner des conditions
d'élevage de transport et d'abattoirs et
d'abattage des animaux
d'un côté la difficulté de
rendre compte de ces témoignages la
difficulté d'accéder aux lieux où sont
tuer les animaux puisque en l'occurrence
là c'est un abattoir et donc je suis
vraiment impatient il faudra attendre le
mois de septembre pour que ce débat
puisse enfin commencer
le procès a été reporté au 4 septembre